and where would it take me
on
we're hopping on the train to everything
in the harry potter books that couldn't
all be included in the films and neither
could some of the other bold choices of
our favorite magical characters let's
take a look at some of the best and most
heart-wrenching deleted scenes that
should have made it in the final cut
number one harry has been on the case of
voldemort since the very beginning at
least in the deleted scenes scenario i
knew the name sounded familiar i read it
on the train that day a young potter
becomes curious about the sorcerer's
stone and the mysteries behind it all of
his assumptions as we know now were very
accurate in this deleted scene the
interesting exchange between harry and
his friends may have just accelerated
his journey to understanding a little
too quickly for filmmakers to keep this
scene in and maybe would have helped us
understand neville's involvement with
putting a stop to his friend's dangerous
endeavors petrificus totalis
number two another way for potter to
feel like he's losing it is for his
classmates to think he's one of the dark
wizards we could see why the scene
wasn't added the length of it was just
too long and the film really did a good
job in showing the horrible position he
was in but wouldn't it have been
interesting for us to see this for the
first time throwing us into a whirlwind
of possibility as to if harry was really
attacking the other students harry
always seemed so nice though the
beginning movies played a little
innocently overall and this scene would
have started the mature sinistrous
nature of the series earlier than we got
to experience seeing
number three another deleted scene from
the chamber of secrets definitely would
have rushed things a little earlier on
harry definitely was on to the whole
horcrux thing you're telling me this now
you must be joking filmmakers were so
careful not to give away any hints to
the folks who didn't read the books that
is why they were so careful when it came
time to talk about horcruxes we did get
a touch of it in the earlier films but
this deleted scene would have explained
a lot of who tom riddle was and why his
diary was so significant hang on
i know that name
number four the gryffindor house was
under attack in prisoner of azkaban or
that's what ron thinks that is
preposterous weasley this take was
actually super informative surrounding
the conflict of sirius black and fills
in some of the blanks regarding his
character ron witnessed sirius break
into the gryffindor common room and try
to stab him though probably a
conversation that was too serious for
all the actors to be in pajamas
number 5 severus snape was always a
little fishy to us in the beginning but
this deleted scene would have really
made us wonder where his allegiance lied
you don't fool me severus
as shady as igor kakarov was in goblet
of fire he did usher in a dark hint into
voldemort's return he confronts snape as
the professor exposes the snogging
teenagers in the carriages but what they
both don't realize is harry is listening
it's happening again like before we
think this scene would have unlocked
snape's plan a little too quickly rather
than the audience having the fun of
figuring out his mysterious intentions
throughout the whole series it's always
fun seeing snape a little intimidated
and ruining the nights of some students
ten points from hufflepuff
number six this seemed like a super
humorous opportunity thrown out because
of the nature of the film with professor
trelawny acting a fool in the order of
the phoenix
happy face we never saw much of the odd
professor but when we did we all fell in
love with her character if this moment
was in the final cut it would have given
us more time with her and just a little
break from the darkness that ensued
really was a good way to support
umbridge's hatred for her too something
you'd like to say dear oh there are
several things i would like to say it's
honestly just great to see a legendary
actress like emma thompson improvise her
character on screen for a lengthy couple
minutes too
number seven the trio detective squad
was on the case of draco since the very
start and they weren't fooled by his
master plan in this deleted cut from the
half blood prince well then that would
explain why i thought malfoy was leaving
the castle this one takes place right
before harry embarks on a horcrux hunt
with dumbledore and harry has some very
compelling statements as to why draco
vanishes from the marauders map he even
alludes to draco using the vanishing
cabinet at borgen and berks to transport
in and out of the castle what if there
are two vanishing cabinets
maybe things would have veered off the
path a little and we'd get to see a
fight with the three of them against
draco we think it turned out okay in the
end but who doesn't love a little magic
fight
number eight poor snape he did the
unthinkable to save the world of the
dark lord's reign and had to sacrifice
more than any other character
this cut was short but provided us a
look into his internal monologue of
hesitation and fear of what he has to do
destroying your best friend and turning
those you love against you for the
greater good is not something one can
just toughen up and do we got to see how
it really affected him and the superior
actor that alan rickman was made the
scene even harder to watch you can see
the sadness in his eyes and possibly an
alternative motive behind what he was
about to do
[Music]
[Applause]
like we said before there were a lot of
deleted moments like this that were so
powerful but might have just rushed
along the mystery of the story a little
too much
number nine one of the scenes that
really hit home for a lot of potter fans
was the final farewell from aunt petunia
in deathly hallows part one and she
wasn't in the dark on this one
do you think i don't know what they're
capable of harry and his friends begin
the perilous hunt for the horcruxes but
must keep their close ones out of it not
saying the dursleys were the most
important people on potter's mind but
his selflessness wouldn't have wanted
them hurt instead of just rushing them
out aunt petunia had one last
conversation with harry that really
moved us
to sister
for the first time she had an actual
moment where we could really sympathize
with the pain she felt once lily potter
passed away the final cut of both
deathly hallows movies never gave her
character an actual human moment and
gave her a little reason as to why she
was always so bitter about the magical
world
number 10 filmmakers just really didn't
see the point in redeeming any of the
dursleys in the final films but a little
love from big d would have gone a long
way to us
i don't think you're a waste of space
not mentioning the constant bullying
dudley did on harry for years this
moment between him and harry even moved
the chosen one this one tied up a loose
end for harry's childhood and finally
showed an actual sincere moment from
dudley
see you big date
number 11 the weasleys on the other hand
have always deserved the best care and
love from the wizarding world you sure
you're right harry gave us quite a turn
when harry and ron break into the
ministry of magic in their disguises
they actually were supposed to run into
arthur weasley even in this moment he
still offers his help to ron's poor
character and family only to be shocked
when harry breaks his disguise to warn
arthur of an impending assassination by
death eaters you know you're being
tracked don't you
this scene was pretty intense and even
added the lovely awkwardness that ron
felt knowing that if his father found
out who he was he'd probably ground him
it's a shame we didn't get to see this
on the big screen but all that matters
is that he was protected in the end
number 12 there was a little controversy
surrounding the sudden and forced
romance between ron and hermione in the
films but filmmakers could have actually
achieved it the right way in deathly
hallows part 1. we would have gotten a
scene where ron teaches hermione how to
skip stones giving them a very
romantically charged moment just saw him
[Applause]
if they added more scenes like this
don't you think it would have made more
sense
number 13 they should have known grip
hook was no good but they were actually
kind of warned before making that deal
with him he won't be forgiving
in fact this scene shows bill weasley
giving a stern warning to harry about
making a deal with the banker grip hook
really creating a tense foreshadowing
moment that would have kept the audience
guessing we think they did a decent job
at hinting at the sinister nature of the
character at the beginning of deathly
hallows part 2. however we wish we could
have seen a more active role from bill
in harry potter's journey
number 14 we have no more tears for the
final scenes of the franchise and one
that will stay in our minds forever is
that fateful shot of lupin and tonks
reaching out to each other after meeting
their demise
there was no moment in the final battle
that we actually got to see them embrace
each other for the last time not in the
final cut at least tonks wasn't even
supposed to fight alongside her husband
but she couldn't stand by as the fate of
the world hung in the balance they both
gave each other a heartfelt embrace that
would have reverberated in our hearts
till the very end wish they would have
kept this scene in but it seemed feeling
the piercing sadness of loss was the way
to go for the final film
number 15 in this last entry we saved
the best for last and we are not happy
this one was left out
our truly favorite draco was destined to
redeem himself in the end and throw
harry potter the one that would destroy
the evil forces they should have never
denied us this moment of draco's
redemption but unfortunately things went
a drastically different way shame we
couldn't get the big redemption we
dreamed of from a malfoy but all's well
that ends well we guess it's quite a
shame that we didn't get to see some of
these deleted moments in the final cut
we would have seen a lot of loose ends
tied up from some of harry's best
friends and worst enemies good thing
they weren't lost forever and we can
still visit the old pontc for them in
the meantime which deleted scene do you
think should have stayed in the final
product
let us know in the comments